The Niagara Fluids content example is a great way to get more familiar with how you can
use Niagara Fluids in any Unreal Engine project.
Inside of this content example map, you're going to find different fluids from fire and
water.
Let's take a look at this now because there's some really interesting things that we can
see inside of here.
So here I have the content examples open.
I have Niagara Fluids.
That's the level name.
You can see here there's just a ton of different types of simulations and things here.
Now some of these we do need to see if I come up here and I'm just going to do a simulate
here.
Some of these will work.
Some of them I actually do need to be playing for this to actually happen.
So let me just right click and we will play from here so we can see.
There we go.
For example, here's a camera facing and non-facing for our 2D.
Here is a torch that has a parented so that it's actually following around as the object
moves throughout the world.
This is 2D collisions and it goes on and on and on.
There's just a whole bunch of great, great, great examples in here.
So again, this is the content examples map.
Niagara Fluids, very, very, very useful and something that I suggest that everybody check
out to get more information on how to use Niagara in their project, especially when
it comes to fluids.